down on the southern 215 beltway you see  some red here because for  some reason somebody decided that that's  a good time to do pothole repair  in the middle of the rush hour now yeah  there's usually more traffic  westbound on the 215 beltway from the 95  515  heading over towards the 15 but  seriously  why here's a live picture this is the  backup around stephanie  now not that there's any good news with  this because basically it's a dumb idea  but it is moving along so it started at  green valley parkway went over to valley  verde now they're approaching stephanie  so follow the parade won't you  we will too john alex i like  i like restrained nate there it's just  unbelievable truly thank you nate